eh bien on va accueillir à notre invité
gérald ollivier journaliste franco
américain qui nous a rejoints dans nos
studios bonsoir gérald olivier merci
d'être avec nous
vous connaissez évidemment beaucoup
mieux les états unis que nous par
définition joe biden est en réelle
rupture avec cet esprit très américain
de libéralisme il veut tenter d'imposer
certaines choses en tout cas fait vécu
comme tel par certains américains
aujourd'hui oui en fait c'est une
question d'être extraite extrêmement
complexe parce qu'elle dépasse le cadre
médical c'est à dire que vous avez à la
fois la question du rapport entre le
gouvernement fédéral et les états
techniquement la santé est du ressort
des états donc le gouvernement ne peut
pas imposer au plan national une
obligation fédérale ce sont les états
qui peuvent le faire en leur propre
général leurs propres frontières de même
que le gouvernement américain
gouvernement fédéral ne peut pas imposer
un certain nombre de règles et demandé
aux entreprises da d'imposer ses règles
elle même surtout si ces règles
s'imposent à des entreprises de plus de
100 personnes et que d'autres règles
s'imposent à des entreprises de moins de
100 personnes donc en fait là on a une
série de niveaux à partir desquels on
peut défier cette loi mais il ya deux
choses qui sont en train de se produire
la première c'est qu'on voie clairement
derrière le gouvernement fédéral
derrière les autorités médicales du cdc
ou du mih qui sont les deux grandes
autorités médicales aux états unis on a
une volonté d'aller vers une forme de
vaccination systématique contre locaux
vides de même qu'elles existent déjà
aujourd'hui contre la polio contre la
variole contre la rubéole qui vit pas
vraiment son nom
en tout cas on exactement en tout cas on
se base là dessus est en avance dans ce
sens là si ce n'est que je pense que le
gouvernement a voulu aller un petit peu
trop vite parce que il passe par une
régulation du travail et que l'agent ce
qui impose cette régulation donc l'
agence de la sécurité au travail cette
agence qui appartient au secrétariat du
travail aux etats-unis ne peut pas
imposer une règle sans que celle-ci
passe par le processus législatif
c'est-à-dire par le congrès donc cette
loi elle est en train d'être défié à
plusieurs niveaux et pour l'instant
l'administration byden a avancé son
premier pion et puis les cours ont
répandu en mettant en suspension de
l'application puis y aura une troisième
étape et une 4e et on n'est pas sorti de
ce processus ça va être très long il n'y
a pas vraiment de surprise dans la
mesure où joe biden avait annoncé la
couleur on se souvient pendant la
campagne il était extrêmement opposé la
vision qu'avaient donald trump 1 de
cette gestion du duc au vide est-ce que
d'une certaine manière je n'en ai pas
parlé de droit mais d'une certaine
manière cette initiative est justifiée
dans le sens du sanitaire ce qui est
ironique dans cette histoire c'est que
lorsque le coc vide est apparu pour la
première fois l'administration trompant
n'était en février mars 2020 on était
alors à l'époque en campagne électorale
et celle admis traces l'administration
trump qui a misé sur le tout vaccinal
avec cette fameuse opération war speed à
travers laquelle le président trump a
imposé en quelque sorte au au
laboratoire de trouver un vaccin d'ici
six à neuf mois et ils y sont parvenus
et décembre 2001 les premiers vaccins
ont été approuvés juste avant vous aviez
eu l'élection le changement
d'administration est une sorte d'un
versement je dirais des rapports au
vaccin parce que tant que trump était
président les démocrates à 10 m est fier
vous de ce qu'on est en train de vous
préparer une fois que 30 n'est plus
président que c'est l'administration
byden qui vient c'est l'administration
de biden qui prend le relais et qui
cherche à imposer ce tout vaccinal et ce
sont les républicains et les états
républicains qui résistent en disant ce
n'est pas à notre gouvernement de nous
dire comment nous comporter donc c'est
là où il ya une certaine ironie
maintenant ce qui se passe malgré tout
c'est que le coït perdure il ya 750
mille décès aux états unis
il ya plus d'américains qui sont mort du
co vide en 2021 que ne sont morts en
2020 et comme le disait votre reportage
récemment il ya encore mille cas de
décès pratiquement tous les jours donc
c'est absolument énorme et c'est
pourquoi l'administration bynum cherche
à trouver un moyen de protéger et de
stopper et que pour eux le vaccin est ce
moyen le plus efficace très tôt ma bonne
et justement cette situation sanitaire
aux états unis gerald olivier a commencé
en nous en parler mais elle ne s'arrange
pas franchement n'est ce pas
oui il ya donc plus de 750 mille morts
aux etats unis ce qui est un chiffre
évidemment considérable il faut rappeler
que la campagne de vaccination avait
commencé très fort aux états unis puis
elle s'est essoufflée au point que
l'objectif affiché de joe biden d'un
certain nombre de la population vaccinée
elle en date du 4 juillet jour de
l'indépendance américaine n'avait pas
été atteint c'était bien la preuve que
cette campagne de vaccination s'était
essoufflé assez rapidement et c'est pour
cela que l'administration de joe biden
veut durcir la politique en matière
d'obligation vaccinale on voit de plus
en plus de mesures qui sont prises en ce
sens en ce moment mais il ya plus
généralement un problème de fracture
entre une partie de la population et
donc la parole officielle il ya par
exemple la figure d'anthony fochi qui
est le conseiller santé de la maison
blanche qui est assez clivant qui est
souvent remis en question par une partie
des américains il ya donc un vrai fossé
qui s'est créé et c'est pour cela
qu'elle est l'administration bayonne
peine à convaincre davantage
d'américains de se faire vacciner et
c'est le sens de ses obligations de
vaccination justement pour augmenter le
nombre d'américains vacciner j'ai un de
dévier c'est un peu comme en france ce
que nous dit un finalement thomas bonnet
un vrai clivage dans la population il ya
les anti vaccins et on l'a ceux qui y
vont ma foi de mon cas oui je sais pas
si ça aussi tranchée qu'en france parce
qu'en fait le problème aux états unis
c'est que vous avez quand même au delà
de 50 millions d'américains qui ont été
touchés par le covan et dont la plupart
d'ailleurs heureusement ont survécu et
donc parmi ces 50 millions d'américains
y en a qui s'estiment posséder cette
immunité naturelle du fait qu'ils ont eu
comment dire est qu'ils ont eu le virus
et qu'ils ont survécu donc ils sont pas
forcément anti vaccins mais ils estiment
qu'ils ne doivent pas être vaccinés
parce qu'ils ont déjà cette immunité au
sein du monde politique on est beaucoup
plus d'accord les républicains en
général pour défendre l'idée de ce fac
de se faire vacciner pour des questions
de santé par contre ils vont aussi
défendre la liberté des états à gérer ce
qui leur revient et la liberté des
individus à gérer leur vie comme ils
l'entendent tout le tout le paradoxe ici
si vous voulez c'est que si vous décidez
de ne pas vous faire vacciner vous vous
exposez vous même au virus techniquement
vous ne menacer personne en étant vous
même pas vacciner vous êtes juste moins
bien protégée à partir de là les
critères habituels qui consiste à
imposer un comportement au nom de la
protection des autres ne s'applique pas
à ce virus d'où une complication
supplémentaire
thomas venait justement par les
politiques il ya évidemment des choses
éminemment politique là en dessous
notamment le gouvernement gouverneur
pendant du texas un qui a pris part à ce
débat déjà opposé l'obligation de porter
un masque là il avait interdire à la
mi-octobre l'obligation vaccinale sur
son sol c'est une fronde et des
républicains qui s'intensifie dans le
cadre d'une fronde plus globale
mais votre invité a tout à fait raison
ces leaders républicains ne sont pas
opposés à la vaccination revanche et
sont très attachés aux libertés
individuelles et c'est pour ces raisons
qu'il ne veulent pas imposer
d'obligations quelles qu'elles soient
dans leur état il ya deux personnalités
qui incarnent cette opposition en
réalité aux obligations c'est greg
abbott le gouverneur républicain du
texas et ron de santis qu'est le
gouverneur républicain de floride ils se
sont opposés à de très nombreuses
reprises à l'obligation de vaccination
évidemment mais aussi du port du masque
dans les écoles c'est à dire une
thématique qui s'est même retrouvé lors
de la campagne pour les élections
gouvernent pour le gouverneur en
virginie puisque le candidat républicain
a beaucoup utilisé l'argument de la
fermeture des écoles en période de
qu'ovide contre son adversaire démocrate
c'est un argument qui avait trouvé un
fort écho dans la population notamment
auprès des parents donc évidemment il ya
un aspect politique même s'il faut
rappeler que la plupart des élus
républicains ne sont pas anti vaccins
mais qu'ils sont simplement attachés à
la liberté individuelle des individus il
faut aussi rappeler qu'il y à une
certain nombre de protestations qui ont
eu lieu notamment dans la ville de new
york où il ya sans doute les règles les
plus strictes du pays en matière de
vaccination là aussi vous avez eu des
oppositions de la part d'employés
municipaux qui ne souhaitent pas se
plier à cette obligation de vaccination
oui geraldo
diversité voilà chantier - d'accord avec
ce qu'a dit votre journaliste à
washington et si je voudrais juste
rajouter pour une petite seconde tiens
y'a pas que des états républicains vous
avez 27 états qui ont déposé un recours
contre cette loi est derrière c est à
vous avez parfois des associations
civiques des groupes religieux des
associations d'affaires dope la cette
loi est contesté à plusieurs niveaux
mais là où vous avez raison c'est de
parler de fronde parce que justement il
ya une sorte d'alliance qui dépasse le
simple cadre politique ou de cadres des
partis contre contre cette loi bâillon
donne dernière petite question ça doit
certainement vous faire plaisir ça y est
on peut retourner aux états unis 18 mois
c'était très long alors que les
américains venaient allègrement visiter
l'europe on est soulagé on est content
c'est c'est normal en tout cas ces
milieux sérieux et puis ça fait en dépit
de ce qu'on vient de dire malgré tout le
virus reculer ces sacs et c'est ça qui
est essentiel et puis retrouver une vie
aussi normale que possible c'est à dire
pouvoir voyager oui c'est important aux
états unis on était un petit peu jaloux
les voir dans les rues de paris et pas
pouvoir aller aux états unis comment
vous voulez en tout cas merci gérald
olivier merci également thomas bonnin
d'avoir été avec nous